[Música]
eu gostaria de ir
fez uma brincadeira um jogo é se vocês
puderem se acertar na metade da metade
para frente da cadeira só como se fosse
com as costas eu estava te a coluna
ereta
todos os olhos assim mais à frente se um
pouco de esforço possível e procurem o
professor nós é só deixar eles relaxados
a pessoa procure se concentrar nessa
postura as maiores apostas em seu livro
sobre os coxas mesmo objetivo na verdade
é conectar se do aspecto os féis as
pernas no chão e observa essa postura
observe por uma baixa de mais de cabeça
por cima bolsa
para além da minha voz
usa o ambiente porque sabe o que você
pensou o que se passa com você quando
você escuta esse som
quando você sente os seus pés nos dados
o chão
na sua coluna ereta um homem com o tempo
de 4
o que vocês encontram percebe da recopa
também de sua posição para vocês fazerem
uma hora a questão agora tendem a ficar
pensando no que está acontecendo
o que vocês estão vendo in hd com sempre
mesmo sem desenvolver nenhum pensamento
só você
isso é importante isso é fundamental não
só o tempo
em cima disso sem desenvolver fez sim
não pensar como sempre sou alguém em sã
arranjos
5 a 0
silenciar entrando
a diferença de temperatura do latim
sáb
sim que ou há
ele sabe
ao vasco
alguém a vida
você tende a aumentar
agora vocês podem
só é preciso dizer quase que a gente vai
usar a venda de que a prática educativa
o que é mais interessante disso tudo a
pesar 200 é uma tradição religiosa
qualquer pessoa de qualquer previsão
josa pode pode praticar e isso é
maravilhoso justamente porque é uma
prática de auto conhecimento
a gente deixa de lado tudo que está
acontecendo o ambiente positivo deixa o
papel focado pela direita mas deixa de
lado coisas que não estão acontecendo no
ambiente
aquilo tudo que a gente inventa aquilo
que é na verdade o produto na nossa
mente da nossa imaginação
os nossos pensamentos e realmente se
fixa
nesse momento
gente com esse autoconhecimento é tão
importante a gente ouviu né
sobre inovação se aplicar essas coisas
assim para que isso aconteça é que a
gente transforme o mundo à nossa volta
só é possível surpresa se nós nos
separamos tirar os conhecidos qualquer
tradição religiosa como eu falei antes
olha o presente pra vocês todas elas na
verdade propõe que a gente olhe para si
se conhece se perceba
então eu estou falando para vocês nada
específico 200 é assim
o maior é o a prática mais importante
que eu usei propõe a sentar se estável e
isso então é fundamental porque quando a
gente faz isso se faz por muito tempo
muitas vezes a gente observa se conhece
e no zen não é não basta ficar nisso é
se conhecer
quando a gente conhece a nós mesmos a
gente começa a perceber que aquilo que a
gente pensa que a gente
outras pessoas sentem também percebem e
isso é maravilhoso porque faz com que a
gente perceba que existem mais pessoas
que pensam igual mas de uma maneira
parecida
essas pessoas é tão aí no mundo tão
respeitados do lado de vocês ea gente
começa a perceber que a gente tem muito
mais semelhanças do que diferenças que
aquilo que me parece horrível quando eu
olho no opel
provavelmente tem também mas a gente
assiste o jornal
e aí a gente ouve falar de um crime
horrendo território
imagina como é que o ser humano é capaz
de fazer isso
a verdadeira isso imagina eu jamais o
que nos diferencia nos separa dos
bandidos
nossos valores
aquilo que a gente estabelece como ética
na nossa e alguns obviamente é isso um
pouco mais flexível não é obviamente
adequado mas é quando nós determinamos
para nós mesmos
isso é certo isso não é certo não é
powell agir dessa maneira
ou é adequado que o animal determinada
maneira
nós estamos usando escolhas estamos
tomando decisões e essas decisões
importantíssimas porque elas falam sobre
nossos ombros então para que isso
aconteça eu preciso me conheceu preciso
observar como eu falei com qualquer
prática desde que vocês verdadeiramente
claro não falam o tempo o brasiliense se
perceber sem dúvida é inevitável vocês
estão se conhece
obviamente não vai ser
vão colocar aquilo que vocês viram
tão letal do buriti mas vai ser
fundamental inclusive porque quando a
gente vê essas coisas também
quando a gente entra em contato com isso
quando a gente consegue né e assumir a
aceitar uma intimidade com com verdade
até essas coisas que a gente não gosta a
gente tem oportunidade de transformar a
transformar em alguma coisa
quando a gente pensa por exemplo em
raiva enquanto a gente só tá sentindo
raiva
nada absolutamente nada de diferente na
nossa vida nos leva a dizer que a raiva
é como uma brasa que a gente quer jogar
no outro
a grande questão é segurança brasil na
minha mão eo jovem guarda
após a pergunta quem mal outro dizer eu
consigo intervalo e não adiantou nada
mas certamente eu vou e para que eu
consiga perceber isso eu tenho tempo de
olhar
e esse tempo aí mas nossa opinião um
jeito nele de jeito nenhum vou fazer
isso
já pensou se você tinha colhido na sua
né na loucura do seu dia a dia trabalho
formais que existe de tudo o raspar o
cabelo já quase nada
a gente precisa colocar a pedra precisa
disso se encontra cinco dez minutos do
seu dia para dentro do trabalho completo
um pouco mais reservado
vamos então como silêncio da sua casa em
qualquer lugar
no mínimo tinha o que você tenha nem
aqueles minutinhos você tem entre a
selar a academia e o horário choro do
trabalho o que é isso
[Música]
o total apresentado né observando a mim
mesmo e ocorreu um pensamento esquisito
encerramento
por isso ela faleceu eu não penso desse
jeito já que a gente não pensa em
desistir quando apareceu na minha cabeça
na pedra
ou será que eu não sei que eu penso
também exige a nossa intenção é que
quando a gente descobre que a gente
também pensa desse jeito a gente está se
conhecendo e cânticos do mapa do céu
mais ou menos assim seja você a mudança
confirmou se as coisas já essas maneiras
e de fato se tem tanta gente dizendo
esse tipo de coisa é porque essas
pessoas provavelmente descobrir alguma
coisa a gente já deve saber
a gente usa essa frase inclusive né
parece casa do facebook nada que fazer
comida que eu vou apostar hoje no
instagram é maravilhosa gols as jogadas
bonitas mas o que ela disse que elas
como ela toca realmente é só uma frase
bonita tabela
ou ela realmente tem a ver com o que eu
quero pra mim a vida é a grande questão
então a gente precisa é olhar para assim
se conhecer e consequentemente tomar
decisões fazer escolhas
eu era jovem eu queria mas há um jovem
quebra quando era mais novo eu tinha uma
vontade de que uma autocracia eu acho
que todo mundo
talvez muitos possível mas quem tenha
quentinhas a fantasia de que ia cuidar
um agente é fazer e acontecer a gente ia
ser sabe pessoas extraordinárias no
mundo vide a conseguir é acabar com os
problemas sociais políticos é que se a
gente se aplicasse muito né as grandes
transformações aconteceria o tempo a
gente começa a perceber que é tão fácil
e acho que isso acaba levando gente é um
certo comodismo uma certa sensação de
que há bons evitá los como consigo
sozinhos e isso talvez não tenha
condições o governo tem a capacidade de
transformar eu vou levar minha vidinha e
tudo bem só geraldo cunha gento essa
inclusão será então a gente vai querer
fazer uma coisa dessas não tá bom tá bom
eu particularmente sempre achei final
sempre achei que precisava de alguma
coisa mesmo podendo transformar o nome
dele
eu comecei a olhar pra mim
z bom se alguma coisa mudar metro de mim
talvez alguma coisa fora de mim também
porque eu estou satisfeito com o que
está à minha volta
não adianta campana informação não muda
em nada a gente
outro dia é evidentemente uma amazona
minha dos 100 me mandou uma mensagem
falando tanto o irmão e ficava doente em
tudo cura a doença em si não resolve
é melhor a gente então procurar e essa é
a grande questão é nós precisamos olhar
o que está acontecendo à nossa volta e
se a gente se indigna com aquilo você
acha que aquilo não está adequado ea
gente pode fazer uma coisa que seja o
momento
depois não é a semana que vem não
resolveu isso porque não tem semana que
vem assim como um homem
este é o melhor momento da vida de vocês
é o único como é possível é isso
a gente só tem este momento
o aqui agora ea gente tem que ir pra
isso tudo acontecer pra gente realmente
aceitar a nossa no nosso olhar é nossa é
a olhar brasil eo autoconhecimento e
consequentemente transformar aquilo é
nós queremos transformar e aí por sua
vez perceber transformações ao nosso
redor pessoas com essa vida diferente e
elas não começam a agir de maneira
diferente da gente é interessante a
gente consegue né quando a gente se
transformaram a gente muda a gente pode
perceber que as pessoas começam a se
tratar de outra maneira porque nós
estamos tratando ela ajuda maneira
fundamental mas a gente tem que ter
claro pra gente um conceito fundamental
independente de ensino um nada apple
será como já fui sempre do mesmo jeito
o tempo quem espera instância quem
espera 11 no oceano macau para navegar
facilitar a vida não funciona
a única coisa permanente na existência é
ter mais ela vai sempre aconteceu
não tem como nós
trocados e essa adaptação só vai
acontecer quando a gente olhar pra gente
porque quando a gente olha pra gente a
gente consegue é percebendo as mudanças
em nós a impermanência que nós a
impermanência é interessante e ela
acontece desde quando a gente nasce
porque está crescendo e se desenvolvendo
a ponto de nós simplesmente não seremos
absolutamente mais nada materialmente
falou
as moléculas comuns o que é de quando a
gente nasceu e trouxe de carga genética
e de material biológico